[Music]
I'm the one
that's
face for real not so let's Okay so by
the way you know for the folks that are
still waiting you're with us appreciate
you we thought this was not gonna happen
this is the benefits of uh Talent
release form lawyers when they get
involved life gets more exciting you sit
there you go back and forth and I'm sure
you love that part of the game you know
what man I I apologize we're down here
uh in Florida my partner and I we were
at the uh the Patriot Awards last night
that's right and I've been wanting the
hook up try and do this show with you
for years but you know the schedule
really is a hot mess and we got here
and there's the release right and I mean
I've signed a thousand releases in my
life but you know the rule we have is I
gotta see it in advance but we didn't
see it and so it's like oh we better
read it and then you know the rest of
the story so apologies for the sign so
in other words a guy named Robert
it's gonna have a meeting afterwards we
already had a meeting with Robert but uh
it's a great way to start his weekend to
when you say that comment on the podcast
he knows what's going to happen never a
good man but listen the fact that we're
getting started would possibly uh you
know maybe the greatest voice we have in
America and and Adam said it best he
says you have a voice for radio but you
have a face for Hollywood with TV is
what you said he said now you're making
it awkward and then
Adam made it weird right out of the gate
there you go welcome to the shop by the
way we've had a lot of different things
that we've been talking about obviously
you're you're probably one of the most
beloved uh uh TV Personalities in in the
in in America and I would say it's it's
hard to do because
people from Left Right and middle like
you
and that's not an easy thing to do no
when your messaging is hard work Dirty
Jobs don't chase Your Passion some of
the stuff that you say could piss off
the other side but they still like you
how do how are you so likable where
people want to hear from you even though
they disagree with you that's an
extraordinarily nice way to frame a
really thoughtful question thank you I
don't I don't really know except to say
that part of it
has to do with Optics and you know I
freelanced in this crazy business for
for 20 years before Dirty Jobs became a
thing and when it became a thing the
Optics of that show at least in the
first season
it was just feces from every species
right I mean most people in the country
got to know me as a guy crawling through
a sewer and so they saw me literally
covered in other people's crap with
condoms stuck to my rubber suit as I
attempted to do whatever the god-awful
job was and so I think part of it was
well whatever this guy has to say
whatever it is he's selling whatever it
is he wants me to think or believe or do
he's covered with other people's crap so
how how how full of crap can he can he
really be you know what I mean it's like
there was so much baked in humility for
that show and and I'm not saying it's
because I'm a humble guy I I'm not
frankly in fact for 20 years I I was
impersonating a host and pretty good at
it you know uh and in in my world you
get paid based on your ability to create
the illusion of competence and uh and
and knowledge in in in short bursts
that's what hosts do Dirty Jobs simply
required me to stop doing that take the
pie in the face let the person I was
with be the expert and assume the role
not of a host or as or an expert but as
a
as an avatar as a as an apprentice
frankly so that's the long answer to
your question I think people got to know
me as a guy who came out of the gate
saying I don't know could be wrong
probably am but here's what I think
and so I got a certain amount of
permission as a result of that show to
to weigh in on things that frankly I'm
really not that qualified to talk how do
you view people you disagree with you
know for yourself like if you uh what is
this you just bought I found this on to
your point Pat we're such an at a
divided time in America today right I
mean possibly and and definitely In Our
Lifetime
um and we talk about being a unifier
versus being a divider sure
um and we had this conversation
yesterday and we were like well is he
more right is he more left and we we Pat
looked into who's following you and it
was people all across the the aisle not
even politically just across the media
Spectrum across everything Ellen and
then Mike Huckabee and you know all wide
range and here I just looked at this
article micro hits number one on top TV
personality like meaning somehow you're
a very beloved figure you're not a
divisive figure and uh well I mean it's
I'm just looking at the stats your
brother I mean this ain't my opinion hey
man it's on the Internet it's got to be
true but look at that hair by the way
holy cow yeah this is amazing well Mike
Mike let me let me ask this here's a
question I want to ask and I know this
is a a
really hard to get something like this
to happen but we're living in a time
where the last two and a half years uh
if you want to talk about divide and
conquer you know split the country you
know magic crowd hates the other side
the other side hates Mega crowd look at
these Republicans these Democrats
provacs anti-vaxx it's so much about you
know I was on a flight the other day guy
sitting next to me on the flight back
from DC the entire time he had his uh he
had his mask on in your mind you already
can say this person voted for you know
what kind of Channel he watches you can
probably list 20 things this guy does
and then you know it's unfortunate but
we kind of are doing that so for for you
whether it's I know you're an Iran guy I
know you you're a big reader you quote
philosophers your guy that was you know
big on
self-development was the concept of How
to Win Friends and Influence People a
natural thing that you grew up with or
was it something your mom taught you
your dad taught you a book you read how
did that personality come about to learn
how to get along with people you
disagree with
um I it was probably a little bit of all
of it but your example is so insanely
relatable I mean I I sat next to a guy
coming out here with two masks on right
and when I sat down he offered me a mask
and I said hey thank you but I'm going
to go ahead and uh and he had already
warmed it up I mean he pulled it out of
his pockets
not what he was wearing no okay that and
so naturally I I offered him my
underpants
no I I I just said thank you
um but I'm gonna you know I'm good he
said okay and um and I sat there and I
thought what do I say to him next I mean
we're gonna spend six hours together and
I it's not like we have to have a
conversation but to your point I didn't
see a mask I saw a Talisman I saw an
indicator of some other set of beliefs
so I stepped back from that and I said
well wait a minute it is is it just a
mask is it something else and then I
thought well what if
what if he doesn't feel well what if he
thinks he might be running a low-grade
fever what if he's actually not scared
but trying to be as considerate as he
possibly can to the people in this
pressurized aluminum tube that are about
to defy the laws of gravity and what if
he's just offering me a mask though may
I might offer somebody a breath mint if
I had an extra one you know what I mean
now do I believe that's where he was
coming from actually no I don't I think
I think he was probably coming from
where you think he was coming from
um but I felt better
thinking that I was sitting next to a
guy who was concerned about me Optics
and then I just went on with my life
yeah you know so look you can assign any
meaning to anything whether it's a mask
or the release I just looked at for the
first time that I wasn't able to
immediately sign because I wasn't sure
what I was doing right and so in those
moments where you're not quite sure
what's happening you either just stick
your head in the sand and go la la and
sign it and hope for the best uh or you
put yourself in the other person's place
and say well why would they why would
they ask me to sign this maybe they're
worried that I'm going to [ __ ] them up
somewhere down the line by by
withholding a permission or something
right and so it's all that if you're if
you're able
and willing and interested to look at
the man behind the mask and ask yourself
a slightly different question then study
after study shows you might not be an
[ __ ] that's a that's a very good
system to consider so the next time I'm
going to sit next to a person with a
mask I'm going to be asking myself and
processing it that way but you know the
whole thing with Talent release form and
why you maybe don't sign it or why we
want people to sign it I remember I'm in
the Army and I'm a Hummer mechanic when
you have an ASVAB of 31 you don't you
don't they typically don't put you as Mi
so right the recruiter says you can be
infantry or Hummer mechanic choose I
said I'll be a Hummer mechanic and I see
next to this fan in the Hummer that I'm
fixing there's a sticker with warning
sign on it says don't put your finger in
the fan while it's running so I look at
the guy I'm like what an idiot who would
put a sticker like this on it and
Sergeant Braxton says the only reason
there's a sticker there is because some
idiot put it right there they got sued
the Army did and then they said we got
to put the sticker here do not put your
finger here so for you and for us I mean
you know we had a wonderful um just a
delightful sweetheart of a guest on the
podcast three weeks ago guy named
Antonio Brown and it was uh I'll Echo
for you oh it was just you know the
entire
unbelievable from the beginning to the
end last after joy you know it's like
like the Christmas morning when you wake
up the feeling was very similar but uh
you know this is this is when you run a
business for 21 years and you come in
initially you're very naive and you're
like man everybody wants me to make it
and they get bigger like holy [ __ ] these
lawyers one after another after another
you got to be a little bit prepared for
it anyways that was very helpful look
couple things so we got uh some stories
I want to go because I like the way you
process issues we got uh we want to talk
musk with you we want to talk FTX with
you we want to talk dirty jobs with you
we want to talk a few different things
about economy with you we want to talk
you what's going on with Starbucks I
don't know if you're following this you
know what happened with Starbucks
thing yeah yeah the union thing look I
want to talk about everything I'll sit
here as long as you want to talk because
I feel bad about that release crap but
one quick point to your point when you
see a sign that says don't stick your
finger in the fan
it does something to your soul and it
does something to the culture at large
that's not good it's kind of like when
you when you unpack something and you
see this bag is not a toy yeah right
it it it makes you crazy because you
know the bag is not a toy and in in so
many ways that's happening all of the
time right now I think part of the
problem with black lives matter and that
whole push and why it brankled so many
people is because we knew it millions
and millions and millions of people know
it and so to be told it presupposes the
fact that you don't know it now some
people might not know it some people
might think that bag is a freaking toy
some people might think that fan would
be a fun thing to stick their tongue in
or their fingers now these people I
don't know what to what to tell you
about these people
they're going to be in for a rough time
but but when we are surrounded and
peppered with idiotic advice platitudes
bromides and all of that
I think it collectively lowers our IQ
and it worries me yeah you know at least
black lives matter was a noble cause
where the founders use the money to put
it into good Charities and not buy
houses and all and you know that I mean
it's just a noble very Noble but uh I
think before we get into all these
stories that was my signal because
today's podcast is sponsored by udemy
let me give our sponsors a quick shout
out we love you to me I think it's a uh
when we go through companies we choose
to uh bring in as sponsors we vet them
out I love the product that they have we
went one time you and I to Utah there
was an event about online courses they
were there we spent a bunch of time with
their Executives they are the largest
online education uh technology platform
in the world they have 50 million
students 70 000 instructors 200 000
courses 65 languages 80 of Fortune 100
companies use udemy to upscale their
employees a couple things one to have an
MBA course I highly recommend to my son
my both of my sons they want to learn
how to edit and make videos I had them
take course on udemy on how to edit and
make videos one of them is 10 the other
is nine they learned a 10 year old and a
nine-year-old learn how to edit videos
at least at the beginning as a beginner
but they took that course another one is
a course that they have for digital
media if you're a salesperson or running
your own business I highly recommend you
check it out as well specifically at a
time like this where we don't know
what's going to happen with recession uh
some of the indicators are showing that
the unemployment is going to go high
next year we're seeing people getting
laid off left and right with a lot of
these big companies this is a great time
and a great season for you to recreate
yourself and to have a holiday deal
going on right now perfect time with
courses on sale for the holidays being
part of entertainment family you do get
a discount so click on the link below to
take any of these three courses or some
other courses that might interest you
Tyler let's put those link below in the
chat and description go there take
advantage of these courses fantastic
okay
Dirty Jobs uh I had the guys pull up uh
two things top 10 most dangerous jobs
and top 20 dirtiest jobs so let's let's
uh which one do you want to go first you
want to go dangerous because you did
Dirty a lot right yeah sure so let's go
dangerous first okay so apparently
according to a study OSHA which uh I
know you work very closely with OSHA
the most dangerous job in America is
fishing and hunting workers okay number
two is logging workers it tells you
fatality look fatal injury 132 out of
100 000. it's pretty interesting by the
way fishing and hunting yeah so logging
workers in 91.7 out of a hundred
thousand roofers 47 out of a hundred
thousand construction workers 43.3 out
of a hundred thousand aircraft pilot and
flight Engineers 30 you know why that
concerns me if you put 34.3 out of 100
000 if the if the pilot is going down
doesn't he wait a minute they're not
flying alone right all right maybe maybe
flight Engineers were listed as two most
dangerous jobs in 2018 but have since
dropped in terms of profession with the
highest fatal injury rate fatal
accidents in these profession commonly
occur because of Transportation
incidents while commercial airplanes
remain to be incredibly safe the most
dangerous aspect of the job is oh
private aircraft correct wow and
helicopters guys that's a big number
though this is not commercial this is
not American Airlines you need to tell
me this is 3.4 out of a thousand I feel
like every time I turn on the news a
plane crashed today and it's just some
dude in a field out there like I feel
like that's every day and you're
introducing me to your friend to buy
private jobs you're so funny that's not
a private private jets aren't sections
with one man two-man every day refuse a
waste and recyclable material collectors
structural Iron and Steel Workers
delivery and truck drivers number nine
underground mining machine operators
farmers and agriculture workers so those
are known as the toughest jobs here's my
question for you
we can take this any angle we want but
I'd love to see if CNN has done a survey
because I know they're all for equal
opportunity and Ms Embassy to find out
what percentage of these dangerous jobs
are being done by men versus women what
do you think since you're in this space
a lot uh well every single one of those
jobs has been featured on Dirty Jobs
most of them I think in the first two
seasons and um yeah I'd say the
overwhelming majority are performed by
men
uh why do you think that is
well
part of it has to do with inertia you
know you start doing a thing then you do
the thing again and it gets easier and
easier to keep doing the same thing
that's that's always part of it but
personally
um you know if you go back up to the
first one you're talking about um
basically hunting and Gathering right I
mean that's what fishing hunting you you
leave the cave you find the the creature
you hit it over the head you drag the
meat back to the cave you eat what you
kill you feed your family and your
identity comes from your ability to do
that in some way shape or form
shows like Deadliest Catch Dirty Jobs
you know they they launched an entire
world of new programs
that tapped in to that basic primal
thing to some degree and it they
awakened in in our gender they awakened
and meant they reminded men in many many
cases in my view that uh that that thing
had not been arbitraged out of our
species yet and we we show you again and
again men leaving the cave to hit the
thing over their head to eat what they
kill and bring the food back home even
in refuse workers even and you you can
go down any job on that list and most of
the 300 jobs I did on dirty jobs but
what's interesting about this list is
the very very first one
fishing there's a very first word up
there even before hunting it's a very
specific kind of hunting and it's a very
specific activity you know they don't
call it catching right it's fishing
there is no guarantee it's interesting
to be the most dangerous job
I uh was trying to sell dirty jobs in
2003 with no real success and the
network said we we do have something
though that we're kind of curious about
which is crab fishing in the Bering Sea
would you be interested in in exploring
that and I said yeah sure
and they showed me some footage little
boats big water it's cold all right and
so I flew from San Francisco to Seattle
Seattle to Anchorage Anchorage one of
those little planes that become a
statistic down in the job number seven
or eight there called Pan Air and they
fly you to the middle of the Aleutian
chain and you land at Dutch Harbor
Alaska
and you get off the plane and you check
into what looks like it might have been
a motel once upon a time and then you
get on one of these boats and you start
fishing and then you realize what actual
fishing really and truly is 20 30 foot
Seas temperatures that can swing 40
degrees in five minutes
you want to talk about danger I actually
thought this was a misprint you'll love
this they they they gave me an Actuarial
chart before I went out on the boat
three columns
uh injury rates catastrophic injury
rates and mortality rates now I'm on
this little Pen Air flight from
Anchorage to Dutch and it's sporty right
all right I got a bush pilot up there
and he's like saying all right folks
hang on we're going to give whenever
you're landing and the and the pilot
comes on and says Ah you know what let's
give it a shot
right you can hear the sound of your
sphincter slam shut and you're just like
the Pilot's gonna give it a shot because
like 40 of the flights that come into
touch they they abort they just turned
back around and they land in Cold Bay or
some other place because you're flying
in between Mountains and the wind is
crazy so I'm on this plane being up and
down and back and forth and I'm reading
these Actuarial charts I'm thinking
somebody's just [ __ ] with this can't
be true what do you think the injury
rate is for a man who works on a crab
boat for a full season which is about at
that time in 2003 is six weeks the
injury rate 20 percent higher 50 higher
100 yeah you're gonna get injured on
those type of jobs or correct Adam one
yes hundred percent yeah that's why I
don't do those kind of things I stay
here on podcasts and to be clear uh a
couple of stitches broken finger right a
mild you know contusion you're gonna get
knocked around for sure guaranteed
catastrophic injury right
percent wow six weeks so yeah uh an iron
pot's gonna slide across an icy desk and
shatter your pelvis all right you know
Jesus You're Gonna Lose an eye you're
you're gonna dislocate an elbow uh a
helicopter is Gonna Come Again flown by
one of these poor bastards down in power
number seven who's probably not gonna
make it back to drag your ass off the
boat right to some Hospital there oh
eight
yeah okay the mortality rate column
three
it's not even a percentage they don't
even give it a percentage number
one a week
one a week right now one a week so again
one person statistically is going to die
every week during the six week period of
crab fishing on the Bering Sea now
people who watch that show which by the
way is now in its 20th season this is
the deadliest catchment this is deadly
this is a show I've been narrating from
the from the gym yeah
um
they know you can't script the Bering
Sea we don't we know something bad is
going to happen but we don't know when
and in in that first season I spent six
weeks up there
when I left everybody I met including me
had gotten injured
one of eight and ten or eight out of a
hundred eight percent had gotten
seriously hurt
and I went to six funerals wow the the
Actuarial chart in 2003
for injury rates and mortality rates on
the Bering Sea was not in fact an
Actuarial chart it was a prophecy
and it came true 100 percent and when I
got back to uh to the states and and
talked to my friends at Discovery and we
all looked at this footage
you know we we realized that the
question you're asking is is not so
different than what
what do people want to watch like what
what is satisfying curiosity really mean
what this discovery
really mean is it is it limited to you
know how the universe works and planet
Earth or or can we look at what it means
to leave the cave and bring home the
meat like is that actually a thing you
can do on on television and when we saw
that footage and we saw real men most of
whom you know the lower 48 doesn't know
exist I mean nobody had ever gone up
there with cameras before much less put
them on a boat much less get to know the
deckhands and the green horns and the
captains and live in the midst of that
shitstorm nobody even knew it was
happening the pribiloff islands what are
those what do you mean you're on 50
miles off the coast of Russia with 800
pound crab pots going over the rail what
do you mean you don't sleep for 48 58 70
hours at a time what do you mean six
people are gonna die in the next six
weeks like all that stuff was unknown
and then all of a sudden it was
self-evident
and that show
in my view is the is the granddaddy of
the shows that answer the question
you're asking which is why do men do
these jobs
why do men watch these shows
why do women watch these shows you'd be
amazed at the number of women watching
but what is it actually I'll be curious
it's not quite half is it 70 30. it's
more like 60 40. that's that's great yes
I think that's great
potentially 55-45 because women are
intrigued by these type of men because I
doubt they're watching it because they
want to pursue that type of career
they're just they want to see what a man
has to deal with what is the the mindset
of a woman watching so that's me going
way out of my Lane let's go there baby
let's go there look I'm gonna stay in my
lane and look at it and say I don't know
but I think
I think when we see something that is
undeniably true it resonates with you
regardless of your your chromosome
makeup you know when when I see women
behaving in a way that strikes me as as
classically feminine right I I love that
that excites me it it it it it it it
makes sense to my brain in a way that
100 right yeah but I feel the same way
when I see men doing these things that
that that lift them up and the species
up and I I know that's not yeah very
correct right now no it is but it's real
bro yeah well I have one question here
this is like the biggest question I had
for micro today I mean you just did an
episode on this on like what it means to
be a man today be a man's man right so
when I think of Mike Rowe I'm thinking
that's a man's man he's doing dirty jobs
he's doing the Deadliest Catch like he
he's doing some manly [ __ ] all right but
at the same token like I'm reading your
Buy you were an opera singer you're an
actor you're a writer you're a TV host
you have you know these uh these
qualities that are you know maybe you
know more liberal arts ish sure so
there's a conversation you should leave
the most important part the guy sold a
hundred million dollars on QVC that too
I mean salesman yeah uh but you know
this the conversation that we're having
you know Pat just did an episode on this
I have an entire show sort of dedicated
to the role of a man and feminism and
what the man bringing home the bacon and
all that
um and we're seeing what's happening
with transgender and their men are
becoming softer and women are becoming
stronger and boss babes and you can be a
CEO and man you can just kind of chop
your dick off and be a female like
whatever not to go there but no you went
there man yeah I'm there uh from Mike
Rose perspective what does it mean to be
a man today
well for starters we don't use words
like chop and dick in the same sense we
just don't do that I agree um that's
probably a job on your list too yeah um
that sounds like a Deadliest Catch right
there I think you know Lorena Bobbitt I
think two sides of the same coin is like
an old adage that's important because
coins are important and coins make sense
to our brain because they're but
fundamental to our to our currency but
ahead is different than a tail you know
in fact sometimes we'll flip the damn
thing in order to solve a disagreement
this is what we did it's a very
important metaphor the coin but the head
and the tail don't appear on the same
side
and if you were to try to make it so you
would have a very confusing piece of
currency and you wouldn't quite know how
to talk about it metaphorically I'm not
even sure what I'm trying to say all
right right now is one of those moments
on QVC where I would just keep making
sounds hoping that my brain would come
up with a really great point
but what you're talking about I think is
polarity I'm thinking he's about to make
a keyboard
I don't want to dismiss some sometimes
it works out Patrick but and sometimes
it's just it's a sinkhole and for the
next 15 minutes you can get this United
States government proof set of coins
what you're talking about is 40 of them
left Duality Duality correct that's
right yin and yang sun and moon light
and dark I mean black and white this is
Duality that's polarity things are not
the same Heaven hell
continue with your coin uh metaphors
well and thank God thank God we have
Duality thank God there's polarity thank
God we live in a world where the
physical Universe still demands that
when the coin is flipped it's going to
be one or the other now there are a lot
of things that I hate about binary
choices Let's Make a Deal was always
door number one door number two or door
number three and the existence of door
number three
is the thing that makes life interesting
the gray area natural it's the it's it's
the basis for our conversation yeah door
number three is always the basis for a
conversation but in matters of clarity
in matters of purpose when we need to
have a quick yes or no then the flip of
a coin is something we can still rely
upon because heads or heads and tails or
tails right and so there is again not to
torture the metaphor but to kind of land
the plane what you're asking goes to his
question too that's why people watch
Deadliest Catch
you you you can't know if it's going to
be a head or a tail you can't script the
Bering Sea you can as a producer have
all sorts of ideas about what you want
to do and then a rogue wave comes out of
nowhere and makes a fool out of you
right it's the same thing on dirty jobs
you can go into the sewer to do a job
and all of a sudden you can find
yourself subsumed in a chocolate tide of
disappointment because something
happened and look the viewer wants an
unpredictable thing We crave certainty
but what we really want is the
uncertainty of not knowing is it going
to be a head or a tail is the Rogue Wave
coming it is Mike gonna get a face full
of crap in the sewer when the lateral
explodes next to his head which of
course it's going to do because it
always does just a question of when and
so all these things come together and
hopefully in the TV world if you do your
job right you give people enough to feel
certain about that they're that they're
comfortable to spend time with you but
enough uncertainty to keep you watching
because you don't really know if it's
going to be a head or a tail you just
don't know
so anyway that's a long way so I gotta I
I appreciate that metaphor and I
actually think it's spot on Pat when you
did the episode about being a man's man
being an alpha you reference the Scott
Galloway NYU Professor he was on Bill
Maher was awesome what was your takeaway
from that that uh what make money have
sex and work out like those three things
he talks about Galloway what about young
men today about how like young lonely
men are the most dangerous men on the
planet yeah essentially your entire
premise that you did in your episode no
it's a great article you know I guess
the question I would have for you is
with with how much did Iron Rand have it
have an influence over you was it
something you read very very early on or
no I read Atlas Shrugged when I was
young yeah how old is Young
um
I was a teenager probably I was probably
18. I was probably 18 when I read did
you do a Fountain Head as well or was a
more Atlas Shrug that a Fountainhead
later okay Atlas Shrugged first but who
gave it to you was it a friend a teacher
was it a parent was a librarian a
librarian gay librarian and how what did
she say to you when she gave it to you
she was a woman
um who actually sort of eavesdropped on
a conversation I was having with a
friend of mine uh in the library and we
were talking about is this in Baltimore
is this in Baltimore okay yeah and we
were talking about uh why people do good
things
and uh selfishness and so forth and so
on and uh and I use the word uh
altruistic and my my friend wasn't
familiar with the term and the library
came over and said it the librarian came
over and said look if you're going to
talk about altruism
you you should read this book
because in it the author essentially
argues that altruism is a false god and
the real key to doing a a selfless thing
a good thing is if it's in your interest
first and foremost and I just thought
the duality of that was super
interesting you know when a mask comes
down in one of those aircrafts on that
list because suddenly there's danger
what are what are we told to do no
matter how much you care about the
person next to you the first thing you
do is you put it on yourself you're of
no use to them otherwise right that
metaphor was really powerful in my life
and uh and I saw it through her writings
you know again and again well now at the
time when you were talking about
altruism were you a believer of that or
were you for the most or were you kind
of trying to figure yourself out were
you okay well I'm still trying to figure
myself out yeah but but I'm talking
about more like philosophy in life you
know do I go am I going to be a
capitalist a rich people bad you know or
you know should I be the one that I
should give everything I have what who
cares about being a millionaire are you
going through that or you kind of
already are a pretty driven self
self-sufficient type of a guy I was um I
was a little suspicious of who I thought
I was becoming I was in the scouts as a
kid in fact I was uh 79 what's the year
I think uh 79 79 yeah so it's about the
same time right I'm a I'm a senior in in
high school and I had just done uh do
this Eagle Scout project and I a lot of
people were thanking me and I was
getting a lot of compliments for being a
nice guy and doing this doing good
things you know one of the things I did
for my project back then was I I read
I read to blind people at the Maryland
School for the Blind I'd read the
newspapers I'd read them uh famous
classical Works
um and I I also helped build a bridge
over at the blind school that my my
grandfather helped uh build with the
Lions Club anyhow
uh and I like the way I felt when people
congratulated me and thanked me for for
doing a good thing but the truth is for
me I had a I had a weird stammer when I
was a kid
um a stutter really and it I was very
shy as a as a teenager and uh part of
what I did to try and get past that was
just put myself in awkward situations
and situations where I had to talk
so my the truth is my Eagle Scout
project was really very selfish it was
great training for me to read out loud
to people who couldn't see me
right wow and so I did that for for
months after school I would go there and
and and they loved it and and I had a
you know once I got over this weird
hitch in my in my voice
my my voice changed early on you know so
people always I sound older like when I
was 18 19 years old I sounded like I was
35 or 40. and so I was able to narrate
shows early on and I was able to do a
lot of things that I maybe otherwise
couldn't have done but my training
really came reading the blind people
and I made a lot of progress doing that
the point is that was rather selfish of
me really I was
you know I I had to do a public service
in order to check that box at that point
in The Scouting program but the service
I chose to do was one that benefited me
enormously it also benefited the people
who you know were listening and so that
that's what appealed to me about einrant
so when you read Atlas Shrug uh is that
where the whole concept of it's okay to
be selfish I mean she wrote a book on
Purely beans I think there is a book
titled selfish if I'm not mistaken she
wrote a bunch of different books
um it made you think what it's okay for
me to make decisions that make me happy
that's how I'm able to benefit other
people is that kind of how you processed
it that's exactly how I've kind of
assistant and how much do you think
where we are today uh you know because
uh when you I don't know if you've
watched your interviews with Phil
Donahue I can watch it on repeat I mean
I just love the way she pushed back and
she you know some of the arguments she
was a little bit weird herself I went to
the restaurant which you were going
right it's in New York it's the Russian
Tea Russian right I would say I would
say take me to the table where she sat
when she would write she would sit right
here so fantastic I did the same thing
did you at the Algonquin with Dorothy
Parker where she used to write all of
her that's cool but anyway good yeah so
I just kind of wanted to see you know
what was the wiring of this lady
who wrote this book and it's unfortunate
that the movie was never properly made
that was supposed to be made yeah by the
same folks that made the Godfather so
let me let me take this too because I'll
tell you how she influenced me
when I read it
I thought about it I said
man what's the purpose of getting
married you know and I know uh you know
or one of our girls came in who was
talking to uh you and uh she says you
know who I'm talking about Kelly who is
here she says he's with his wife I said
I promise you he's not with his wife
that could be his girlfriend but it's
not his wife because he's never been
married correct and he's never had kids
so I'm I'm sitting there at 27 years old
and I've obviously had read this book
early in my 20s and I said I'm like what
is the purpose of marriage do I really
want to get married my parents got a
divorce twice to the same they married
each other and divorced twice and I said
I've never seen a successful marriage do
I really want to deal with you know one
guy I spoke to about marriage she had
four kids and he says you know if you
really want to be a billionaire and be
super super successful get if you are
going to get married get married to
somebody who already has three kids I
said what I asked another guy now the
people that get married and have you
know family are the ones that have the
highest chance of you know succeeding in
business not guys I would talk to were
Playboys nah listen man you don't want
to deal with this just stay single and
you can have a good time and later on in
your life if you want to have some kind
of a companion you should do it but
here's a guy who's a startup studs you
Eagle Scout got the voice Got The Look
got the height you know is gone around
the world you've done good for yourself
I am sure you've had tens of thousands
of options to say yes what was your
processing and I've read the articles on
you to see what you know when you
explain why you didn't but was there a
moment where you're like yeah I'm just
not gonna do it I don't think I want to
get married and I want to have kids what
was that conversation like
Jesus that's a lot man but let me start
by saying that
um again I think the first thing we said
when we sat down was you can assign any
meaning you want to anything that
happens and so for me uh I was
surrounded by perfect examples of the
institution working ideally never mind
Iran I mean in general I like a lot of
what you said and some of it I thought
was crazy town I just dismissed it I I
have no problem taking you know the the
stuff that I think is useful and
dismissing the things that don't work
for me
um but
my mom and dad
in fact when I leave here I'm going up
to Baltimore they're celebrating their
62nd wedding anniversary tomorrow wow
the day after my dad turns 90. okay
they've been in love for 63 years that's
crazy right it's great now it gets
crazier than that I grew up in a little
farm in Northern Baltimore County and
next to us was another couple Carl and
Thelma Noble they happen to be my
grandparents and they were madly in love
till the day they died is this the
grandfather that influenced you to be an
eagle scout and build a bridge same one
okay correct uh and so I had a mom and
dad who walked the walk and talked to
talk and so I knew exactly what that
sort of marriage and relationship look
like and next door
I had this other example this beautiful
marriage of these beautiful people and
so I there was never any doubt in my
mind that this is a great institution I
did have some doubts as to whether or
not I could measure up
and so the meaning I assigned to it was
look if if it happens it'll happen if
you're going to make it happen if you're
going to force it to happen because you
because you're coming from some sort of
place where it's been written in the
stars that this is what you ought to do
well then you can make that happen too
but I just didn't want to I just didn't
want to force it and so for a a whole
bunch of weird reasons the various
relationships I've had combined with the
trajectory of my career
I I really kind of step back from all of
it and said I'm not I'm not going to
abdicate my responsibility in making
choices but I do not have a plan I'm not
writing this down this is not step one
step two step three I want it to be
I wanted to be conscious about what I
was doing and about the choices I was
making but I also wanted to be a little
bit of that feather in the beginning of
Forrest Gump just kind of like well
let's see where it goes because to me
the world is is big and interesting and
you know people who are certain about
what they want to do and write books
about how to achieve all of those things
that's cool that's interesting Ayn Rand
did that you know her whole she she
created a philosophy about this whole
thing so you know I in the end
just decided I was going to take my cue
from the next day and play the cards I
got as best I could and it served me
pretty well professionally and
personally frankly you you you you don't
think
um
uh you know like sometimes we sit there
and we're like well you know you know
what would happen if I would have
actually taken School seriously become a
lawyer well you know you're pretty good
at debate what kind of a lawyer would
you have been would you been running a
law firm well no it kind of worked out
for you so stop talking about what if
you would have done this life's been
okay with you getting into the insurance
industry which you know you did okay
there well what if this what if that you
seem like a very uh deep value uh
meaning of a life contribution
understanding like you're the kind of
guy that if we had dinner with I would
just want to sit there and you talk 99
of the time telling stories I'm probably
going to walk away learning so much from
you there's a lot of depth uh well look
thanks depth in you and it's just felt
it's not even like this isn't like a you
know I'm complimenting to compliment
it's felt and I'm not the only one it's
very natural it just comes out of you
right do you sit there and you say you
know like you know the Jewish proverb
I'm sitting on like dude I I just want
to I just wanna I enjoy I'm the guy that
goes to movies by myself and I enjoy it
I'm telling you because I I I would go
to movies I'd say to my assistant uh I
got an appointment to run okay and as
you're gone what were you at she said I
had an appointment why you have popcorn
on your top like well you know I had an
appointment I told you an appointment
and I would watch movies with uh Anne an
85 year old woman at 10 o'clock in the
morning you know and these people would
be lined up hey Patrick what are we
gonna watch today I'm like I don't know
whatever let's just go sit there and
watch a movie so I enjoy my own company
but then I read this Jewish proverb you
know three things man should do you know
plant a tree which I haven't done yet
but very disappointing yeah
um number two on the most dangerous Lady
by the way yeah planting season I'm
gonna stay away from that nobody talks
about when it falls on your house right
so plant a tree the other one is what
write a book and then you know have a
son right because it continues and
you're able to do that do you sit there
and you say man I got so much to offer
you know what would it look like and by
the way you're living at a time where
I'm sure you could have a kid or two or
three I think some people we know have
kids in their mid 60s do you think about
there and say maybe you know it'd be
kind of cool because at a time like this
where we're seeing some troubled
teenagers what statistics of a bad
father or you know not even a bad father
somebody that's not even in the picture
what that impacts what could a you know
micro raise [ __ ] I mean that that that
kid is gonna be a positive net positive
to society do you think about that at
all no not much really not much I used
to a little bit but you just can't know
that by the way if you're sitting in a
theater
by yourself you're not alone
you're there with the film you're there
with the people on the screen and uh and
that can mean as much to you as you want
it to I get lost in movies I get lost in
books and and I like being lost in those
things because I don't like to be alone
I like to be by myself
but I like to be alone right so the
movie is a powerful metaphor it's my
first job the first paycheck I ever got
was a projectionist for United Artist
actually it was for an usher then it was
for a concessionaire then it was for a
cashier then it was for appellationist I
was still in high school I was uh I
started there when I was 17. huh and um
yeah two dollars ten cents minimum wage
1978. but um I'm sorry what was the
other part the whole question about the
fact that you sit there saying hey you
know the kid part just purely the kid
part by the way to me it's not even
marriage it's purely the kid part yeah
so
foreign
my Foundation
has helped 1700 kids at this point
getting scholarships to weld and
plumbing and steam-fitting pipe fitting
and so forth and so on
um I'm not saying that that's the same
as having a kid it's not it's not even
close but the I think the reason having
a son is on that checklist that you just
went down is because
because a man ought to be able to see
the needle move a man ought to be able
to see
an impact on on another man a boy you
know you you want to be able to make a
difference you want to think that your
ideas and your beliefs and your words
and your Deeds can help shape something
and so that is not something I'm willing
to to give up but I really wonder you
know uh I mean
Gerald Ford
was adopted you know the president of
the United States had one of the one of
the worst fathers you could possibly
have and uh his mom Dorothy uh finally
got out of there and the paint salesman
who married his mom
uh his name was Gerald Ford he he gave
the boy his name and he raised him
like a man ought to raise a son and if
you ever read what what Gerald Ford went
on to say about his adoptive father
versus his actual father then you're
left with no choice
but to ask what what is the real
relevance of the DNA what is the real
impact I mean
I just don't think there's ever
I don't think there's a better example
of an easy thing juxtaposed with a hard
thing how easy is it to slip it in there
have the kid how easy it is it to to
make a woman pregnant and how hard is it
no question about how hard is it right
yeah for the next 18 20 or you've asked
my dad today he'd say yeah man he's
still my dad 60 years later he's still
he's still being a dad so yeah having a
kid peacek
but that's coming from a guy
you your shows are based on the hardest
job and the dirtiest job and I don't
know a harder job or dirtier job than
being a parent you know I don't know if
they put that at the top of the list but
no I just thought about you and I'm like
you know you know there's certain people
that you're like dude like
you're getting a little too much
attention right now and you should not
be a celebrity because you're bad for
societies dude this guy should have 50
million followers he's a talent he would
be a freaking awesome uh uh net positive
for society I just think about it I'm
like you know uh
because of me at 27 uh uh I went to
dinner one time at this one restaurant
in Beverly Hills it's one of the top
restaurants I forgot the name of the the
waiter comes extremely flamboyant
personality mid-50s good looking guy you
know sharp joke stories has been there
for 30 years so I said so he said so
what's this date all about I said well
you know I think we're at the phase
right now we've been dating for about a
year I don't know if I want to get
married or not I'm sitting on my date
it says you want to tell you my lesson I
said what's that he said I got nine kids
and I've never been married before
everybody that I got pregnant that has
one of my kids they signed a contract
that have zero responsibility for it and
they agree to it so why the hell would
somebody do that with you like you're
not that you're a waiter like why would
you that's not an unbelievable story I
understand if somebody said yeah hell of
a waiter says well let me tell you if
you only knew under all this stories
just tell them I'm like I could I'm
sitting there saying I don't know you
know I I don't know I don't know I'm
obviously people make impacts in a
different way but I only asked that
question for my own uh selfish reason
because when I was 27 I almost chose
that route oh me too yeah oh many many
many close ones very very close right I
mean I never ruled it out until today
I'm still done now no I'm okay cool it's
still open on the agenda I don't really
well by the way let me just tell you our
real our real sponsor today's Bumble and
uh Tinder uh we are announcing today
that Mike Rose profile is official can
you please put the link below
he gets 17 000 swipe rights
I've got a question
um so I'm
sort of
in the middle of all like Pat's a father
of four okay he was a former you know
bodybuilder good-looking guy Hummer
mechanic you know Playboy businessman
entrepreneur now he's an amazing father
amazing husband he's a leader right you
have Tom the biz doc over there two
wonderful daughters he's you guys are
very similar age right very good father
Pat tells the story of how every night
he calls his wife and calls his kids and
prays with them you know I'm in a phase
of my life I'm in my early 40s where
I've done the relationship things over
and over and over again whether I get
married or not especially to the
government remains a question whatever I
like women
um but being a father
is 100 on my agenda like I look at Pat's
relationship with his kids specifically
Dylan what a stud he's what nine years
old eight years old oh I love this kid
my nephew Rory 10 years old
I love this kid he's awesome my guy
Fabian over here okay he came in
yesterday have you did you meet fabian's
four-year-old he likes it is that's my
only concern he likes what onions he was
having onions we'll make it work though
it's like I see I said Fabian like I I
understand you a little bit better now
like I look at someone like Bill Maher
who's who's definitely a mentor role
model I look at him especially
politically and and being a former
comedian and you know offering insight
and wisdom and I look at him and and and
he's very selfish and we just talked
about that with iron Rand you be as
selfish as you want bro I'm sure he's
you know had a ton of women and smoked a
ton of weed done a ton of drugs made a
lot of people laugh but for someone like
Bill Maher to not have that Legacy like
a kid and he seems very comfortable with
that sure I don't like I don't think I
would be very comfortable me not leaving
the legacy of having a kid that's very
important to me but like what you said
about well I've you know uh 1700 kids
and that was the moment I was like he's
done something very unique that most men
can't do you know they say like any man
can be a father but it takes a real man
to be a dad right like to be there to be
president he's talking about but you
seem very you're 60 years old bro you
look great but you know you're on the
the second half of life so to speak even
though you look awesome there's nothing
in your DNA saying all right
gotta pop one out I gotta have one no
and nothing no I mean
maybe something but
there's a lot of space between nothing
and something zero to one right Peter
Thiel I mean it's not I I'm hesitant to
use words like nothing never
always all always never yeah I I just
don't I just don't buy it
um but uh yeah so I I guess I'm a man be
pamby Never Say Never guy
in that space But you know your earlier
question I thought was was even better
uh you know you mentioned the Opera
right
um
and I only bring it up because I I think
part of
what's happening today is there's we
don't do well with cognitive dissonance
and if you know me as the Dirty Jobs guy
and if you've seen me crawling through
the sewers and if you've seen deadly
sketches and then you learn I sang in
the Opera right you got a problem right
it's like wait a second one of these
things is not like the other you're
supposed to be the manly guy why are you
singing in the Opera but so if you're
singing the Opera you know what so what
at and you were on QVC for three years
so so you're a salesman which means
you're an opportunist and you sang in
the Opera which means you're maybe super
in touch with your feminine side and
like like and so all of a sudden all of
these things are are on the page and
that page is under the light of some
level of publicity and celebrity and
people start drumming their fingers I
had a show on CNN for three years
I just presented an award last night at
the fox Patriot Awards I'll be on CNN
next month promoting the return of Dirty
Jobs and then I'll walk across the
street and sit out on Fox and talk about
how America works on Fox Business right
so you know you you started off very
kindly by talking about this this uh
this weird space that I'm occupying on
the Venn diagrams that typically don't
overlap and I'm so grateful to be in
that space you know because it's it's
it's hard to find it and no one wants
you there and you know the people from
the old days who I sang with
the people who I did theater with they
look at this whole Persona thing and
they're like what how did that happen
right and the people who know me best
from my foundation and the people you
know who have in the last 20 years they
they can't reconcile
what what I did in my in my youth for
money yeah right I mean I sold
everything I had every sales job there
was if there was any any performing job
I would try it you know I got in the
Opera because I lost a bet I got in QVC
because I could talk about a pencil for
eight minutes right I didn't want the
job but once I got it
that was a new bunch of cards to play
and I thought that was interesting I'm
not a trained singer but they gave me a
shot
and I got a foot in the door
the Opera was a world Broadway was a
World Sales is a world the sewer is a
world the deck of a crab boat is a world
the flight deck on a plane is a world
and the men and women who live in those
worlds they're more they're more
complicated than the one-dimensional
identity we insist on handing them right
we all have some weird Opera thing in
our past and Adam we all Wonder Jesus am
I really going to leave the world
without leaving my mark on it but I
would say
is that rooted in
just simply self-preservation
is it rooted in selfishness is it rooted
in altruism is it what the hell is it
well doesn't it come down to Legacy at
the end of the day yeah but yeah but
you're not in charge of your legacy it's
just like if you're in a theater
watching a movie by yourself you're not
alone we'll we'll decide what your
legacy is well I if I can give you a
little pushback I feel like you can
control your legacy and the narrative so
for instance that when I when I started
my whole social media Escapade I was a
former nightlife guy in South Beach
Party guy I said I gotta get out of this
world this is crazy I'm gonna end up an
alcoholic drunk drug addict I've seen it
too many times I got into the financial
world I started off as a cold caller
paid my dues met Pat in the insurance
space I've been doing that for 15 years
now made a bunch of money had success
Life's good right but five years ago
speaking of altruism you know I had a
selfish Gene I wanted to create a
personal brand and I started a show
basically interviewing a lot of
financial types of people about about
money and basically specifically what
young people should understand about
money and I did I I mean when I tell you
I did thousands of Street interviews
from financial advisors and CPAs and
estate planners to college kids and
people going to clubs and uh just party
people and I remember I was at this one
event
it's called the heckerling estate
planning it's the the top of the top of
the top of the list it's the one percent
of the one percent advisors who go there
and they're dealing with eyelids and
trusts and irrevocable like the most
heady boring stuff ever and I'm not that
guy like I'm like talk to me like I'm a
fifth grader sure and I said guys let me
ask you you know after you've done
making the millions and the billions and
this and that I said what's next and
they said well leaving a legacy and
that's why they're all doing
philanthropic Endeavors and starting
Charities and charitable funds like you
talked about the 1700 kids you've helped
with your charity and all these people
they've already made an impact they've
already made the money but they want to
be intentional about leaving a legacy
but you can't dude yeah I'm telling you
I feel the same way I can go down my
list of attempts hopes dreams and
accomplishments you know not to get
biblical on it but those would be
described as a pile of dirty rags you
know what I mean you we all do what we
do and we do our best at it but how I'm
remembered that's up to you that's not
up to me how you're remembered you it's
kind I look at it like once the pitcher
lets go with the ball it's truly out of
his hands so his legacy regarding that
pitch
really is more up to the batter than it
was to him or it's up to the market both
of you guys are making me think because
the way I see it is I fully agree with
your point but I also fully agree with
you I think it's kind of like you're the
lawyer making a case for your life and
the jury and the judge is saying yeah
now it was an okay life it's just like
no you know it's kind of like you know
that one of my favorite movies the judge
with Robert Downey Jr where Robert
Robert Duvall oh my God I watched that
movie on one flight back to back like
literally back by yourself from by
myself and it was just a it was a very
very yeah but I think that's what it is
I think a part of it is here's here's
the other part here's what matters to me
I think I believe this is what it
matters to me the most
so you're a salesperson you're a talent
you're a philosopher you can be called
seven different things is what you are
you're not one person or the other right
you're creative
and you know uh uh I can sell myself you
know you can sell yours we all can sell
ourselves once you learn how to
communicate I remember John Maxwell in
the book says you know there's a once
you learn how to persuade be very
careful because you're one step away
from knowing how to manipulate you got
to be very very careful when you learn
the art of persuasion fine
I can say whatever I say on that camera
accent whatever I can say in the crowd
here we got say a thousand people were
speaking to say we're at MGM Grand Arena
annual I can't give a message then later
on that night when everybody's asleep
and I'm sitting in the living room and
nobody is there
no wife no kids no audience no clients
no fans no critics nothing
if I'm a hundred percent cool with the
decisions I made who gives a [ __ ] but I
better be a hundred percent I think
that's the one part I better be 100
when's the last time you were 100
um
I I was about kids
uh marriage you know I always talk about
marriage because you can't control the
other person you don't know what's going
to happen with marriage we've been
married now for 13 years going on 14
years
and uh I read on the second book we read
a book called I had a I bought a book
for on our second date second date the
book was called 101 questions to ask
before you get engaged second date I
give this to her at Borders when there
used to be a borders
a week later we go through the question
at her place six hours
and I'm sitting there saying 60 chance
this could work I never said 100 I'm
being I don't think you can say marriage
100 yeah because it's the other person
but forever that person is going to be a
partner of yours a wife of yours or an
ex-partner or an ex-wife or the mother
or the father of your kids there is a
partnership still that happens right
that part is a hundred percent could be
an ex could be a wife could be a husband
could be an x 100 percent
um
starting a business a hundred percent I
wasn't going to choose the alternative I
couldn't do it it's very very hard
but it's not a lot of things that's a
hundred percent just so you know and I
would put the short list of man less
than five that I would say 100
um but but you know what it is here's
the other part the other part is say I
make a decision that I'm not 100 about
but I'm by myself and I'm a guy that
sleeps late and I like to I like
thinking I like you know I like sitting
there and just kind of like you know
processing issues how could I have done
this differently and I'm that guy I'm
the guy like what do you mean sleep
slate well I mean I I I'm anyways I
would what are you gonna do we have
different definitions of sleep sleep you
sleep in you mean no no no no what I
mean is I'm up when everybody's asleep
and I'm thinking oh you go to sleep late
gotcha no no I'm a six hour guy I'm a
four to six hour guys
yeah I I thought you were saying you
know I'll just lay in bed till 11 no no
that's the opposite
forgive my English guys it's efl English
English you go to bed late I go to bed
not sleep late no no I go to bed late
correct I go to bed late so I'm sitting
take it I'm like and and you know I'm uh
grew up in a family of paranoia Iran
wore some naturally paranoid uh you know
you make investments
Investments you kidding me there's
nothing 100 right you know you're saying
like hey do we do the right decision
here should you know do we do that I'm
that guy right you're constantly
thinking there's a certain things at
core values I'm on 100 camp on but it's
not a lot of things you know it's not a
lot of things and it's it's it's tough
that's the part that's tough you know
it's apart that stuff but again if you
know uh if a person can sit there and
say I'm cool with my decisions who gives
a [ __ ] about all the other parts of it
if a person can sit there by themselves
and say I'm totally fine with what I'm
doing no problem but it's that battle of
you know like for example when you were
saying something uh I used to hang out
with some Seattle Seahawk back in the
days when I said Seattle Sea not Seattle
Seahawks Seattle supersonic you know
when you say Seattle SuperSonics people
have no clue what Seattle Sean became
Oklahoma Thunder so but it was back in
saying you know you would look at the
life and the party and you're like dude
why the hell are you married
like I don't think NBA players NFL
players Hollywood I don't think you
should get married for a minute
because what are you talking about like
Tiger Woods well listen did you hear
what Tiger Woods did yeah bro why don't
you go become the greatest of all time
and see what it's like to walk outside
at Walmart go and try it out go do it go
go golf since two three years old have a
perfect swing and then go to Costco
tonight and then see what happens when
you go to Costco see what's thrown at
you sure when you go to Costco the
customer service throws you know towel
at you man she he goes to Costco you get
panties thrown at you if your name is
Tiger Woods right go see what that life
experience is it's called a dirty job
right okay
um Costco I love how that you're going
Costco I'm going nightlife bars but the
point this guy can't go to Costco right
he's not allowed in Costco tiger can't
go to Costco can't go into catastrophe
the owner of Costco the manager of
Costco is going to say get out we have
protests outside bro get out we're
having problems here right so but but
the point is you know when you when you
think about this stuff is there are like
when you're saying oh I went in I'm in
Alaska for six weeks and I'm really
trying to see exactly what their job is
like what if you're outside of Russia
and I'm here yeah that not a good idea
to be married if you're out there on the
road you know military I was in the
military I mean such and such place for
18 months haven't seen my wife for 18
months that's probably not a good idea
right yeah it's probably not a good idea
so in that part
I totally see the argument if that's the
job
there's a part of me that says dude
you'd make one badass of a father bro
you would make one BMF of a father like
you would be uh if you know you you'd be
you'd be
God knows who you would raise God knows
God knows he knows that's right God
knows I know he does okay so let's
transition away from this and into other
topics Tom you look like you wanted to
say something yeah every time next time
honestly let us speak next time when
we're doing a podcast a little bit too
much interrupting this time next time
let us let us say some words but go
ahead I'm warmed up inside don't worry
about it
you know Mike you you talked a little
bit about the foundation what I'd like
to see is you you have this incredible
macrame that kind of was woven out
through all of these steps that happened
through your life and at some point on
there obviously success brings Financial
enablement you decided to do the
foundation
and I'd love to understand the Genesis
of it because the premise of it I love
it's like hey you're sold go to college
get a good job but that's not
necessarily the only product on the
shelf that that you can buy you know
you're being sold that product but
there's there is other Alternatives in
life and you you've dedicated yourself
to building the foundation to show
people that you know through trade
school and other things that you might
be surprised at the local plumber makes
50 bucks an hour right there's a lot of
things that uh people don't know about
it
I dedicated the second half of my career
teaching and that's you heard the phrase
bizdoc that's my alter ego and I have a
simple Credo it says you know on the biz
Doc and I hope I left you better than I
found you I don't know I'm gonna try but
I just hope but it doesn't make me
better or worse if I don't I just hope
that maybe I can impart something that
gives you a hand and teaches you what
was the Genesis moment obviously with
some Financial enablement so you could
create a foundation that led to you know
what I'm gonna put this Foundation
together because I got some messages and
I've got some assistance that I can give
these young men
uh 2008 Dirty Jobs uh is the number one
show on Discovery maybe maybe the number
one show in the network
um
certainly on the network maybe on cable
um the show is in 180 countries and I
was doing great and everything we'd been
on five years and the country was going
into a recession
and it was shocking how how quickly you
guys will remember how oh yeah how fast
things crash September of October of 08
thud that's well so I started micro
Works uh on Labor Day
of 2008 and I started it because wow we
were on the road in those days
living in motel sixes and super eights
and getting up every morning and you
know I'd pick up the newspaper and I'd
look at the headlines and it was just
always always always unemployment
numbers there was always how many people
are out of work and I remember watching
It Go five six six and a half seven
seven and a half eight you know over ten
percent
on dirty jobs everywhere we went uh I
saw Help Wanted signs
and so something
was happening in the country that nobody
was talking about and it had to do with
what I thought at the time was a
mismatch of skills so you had 2.3
million jobs that people couldn't seem
to hire for and these jobs by and large
didn't require a four-year degree they
they required training
and uh you know after these jobs I would
always go out and have a beer with the
people that I worked with and I always
ask them the same question and it was
always the same answer it was just we
our single biggest challenge is finding
people willing to show up early stay
late and take a bite of the crap
sandwich when it comes along learn a
skill that's in demand we just can't
find it couldn't find it five years ago
now it's virtually impossible so the
foundation started
in a way now that I think about it for
the same reason I read to the blind I
wanted to do something good for somebody
other than me but I also wanted to
benefit from it to be completely honest
so it began as a PR campaign for what I
believed were a couple million
opportunities that were going unloved
right and so I wanted to talk about
those opportunities in the same way that
a dirty jobs
was designed to shine a light on humans
doing these kinds of jobs I just wanted
to look at the jobs themselves and say
hey America not for nothing but
right these guys are killing it
as plumbers and here's how you do that
so it began as a PR campaign it took me
to Congress a few times we got some
attention as a result of all that and
then some companies who were struggling
with their own recruiting challenges
came and I started working with them
because you know as you know a company
is
it's its own least persuasive Advocate
and a recruiting message is not so
different than a marketing message
and the [ __ ] meter for people today
is very very high right and so companies
do a really poor job by and large of
making a case for themselves so I became
somewhat useful to big companies and
helping them tell the story of the
opportunities that existed underneath
their own umbrellas and then um it sort
of morphed into a trade Resource Center
fans of Dirty Jobs
um helped me build an online resource
that would just direct people to zip
codes where these jobs existed and then
we would attach things to that direction
like apprenticeship programs that were
available in other ways to get the
necessary training and so forth and then
it was a scholarship fund
and uh I guess it was maybe 2012 I
started to raise money for that and
we're we're modest by Foundation
standards but we give away we just gave
away um one and a half million dollars
in work ethic scholarships modest six
stipends right but but they're not for
kids who want to go to a four-year
School these are specifically for people
who want to get trained for a skill
that's actually in demand and so we've
been at it now 15 years and what I
learned along the way was this is making
a difference in people's lives on a on a
micro level which is awesome it's making
a different micros life which is awesome
but on a macro level it's it's it is
having an impact on the skills Gap and
it is helping shape
a broader conversation about the
definition of a good job and so we're
about seven million dollars in now
um and the biggest thing that's happened
Tom that that I that I didn't anticipate
was that the stories I tell shifted from
my own anecdotal experiences and
suspicions and beliefs about what's
going on in the workforce
to actual testimonies from a welder who
five years ago we assisted who now owns
three vans hired half a dozen people
heating air conditioning electric
plumbing has a mechanical contracting
company does a couple million dollars a
year so it's this uh Nexus of
Entrepreneurship uh a willingness to get
your hands dirty and understanding that
opportunity might not look like the
thing you were you were told it looks
like and
um
and all of that just kind of smeared
together and so the for me the great
Good Fortune is that my Foundation
Rhymes perfectly with my identity in the
industry Dirty Jobs and how America
works
are the same basic show
on two competitive Networks justified by
an underlying Foundation that actually
gives me permission to come on shows
like yours and say I think
I think you can still read to the blind
dude in a way that helps everyone the
reader
and The Listener and and that brings us
back to to ran powerful and it just
brings us back to look I
here's what I don't want any of your
listeners to be confused by I'm it's
tempting really really tempting to sit
here and say Let me let me tell you how
I did it here was the plan and here were
my action steps and here's my legacy
that I've got my eye on right none of
that happened for me it was simply put
your head down do the next job
get in the hole Crawl Through the sewer
get on the crab boat crawl up the bridge
meet the men shake their hands listen to
their stories let them be the expert and
then get out of get out of the way go to
another town do it again and
in doing that again and again
and then talking to the woman you
mentioned earlier Mary who's with me now
who's the only business partner I've
ever had never had an agent never had a
manager never had a public really yeah
how long has she been with you 18 years
damn so is that is it just business
partners it's it's I mean it's
everything okay good yeah I mean it's
not that oh okay it's not that but it's
it's bigger than that you know Mary and
I have uh we can communicate without
talking you know she
she was running a a really
well a boutique Law Firm representing
some really big clients and she got a
phone call from me uh from a sewer I
negotiated my own deal with Discovery
right and um in those days I negotiated
for
for failure because my business model
wasn't based on success at all it was
based on touch everything like it's hot
I was a freelancer I had 100 jobs a year
by and large I wasn't looking for a hit
and uh so I shrewdly negotiated my own
deal which gave them the right to do
whatever they wanted in the Advent or in
the event of success of course there was
no success you know in my mind there's
no way anybody's going to watch the show
anyhow it blew up
and I needed help so I I found her and
and so yeah she looks at a release and
says hey have you thought about this and
I said oh okay maybe I should think more
we all need people like that we had a
guy we had a guy on our team I I'm not
going to say his name we have we just
had a transaction five months ago we
sold one of our insurance companies and
we spent a few million dollars on legal
fees accounting all this stuff just in
the last six months anyways so we're
going through the process and
I'm interviewing our attorney who we've
used for the last six years five years
we get a call from the other side
attorney
and they say listen man we've never
dealt with an attorney like this before
and I said let me give him a call it
says no we we deal with a lot of
attorneys this guy is a ridiculous
attorney so I give him a call and we
have a meeting together our group on how
to manage this guy moving forward I said
guys we just have to realize sometimes
in life be happy when the guy who's a
pit bull is on your team this guy's a
pit bull he's on our team we're good the
weirdest guy most meticulous detailed
annoying as hell for the opposition but
he got the things done in the contract
that we needed it so when you find
lawyers like that 18 years we feel the
same way as well we protect guys like
that having said that there's a guy that
needs lawyers right now I don't know if
you guys know this guy or not Sam
do you know this guy's story or no are
you following that story at all how
awesome that his last name has the word
Bank in it
[Laughter]
come in free are you kidding me yeah
yeah you know about the paper that his
mom wrote do you know the story that
came out about the paper that his mom
wrote so let me first read one of the
stories of what happened uh and we'll do
a couple stories and then wrap it up so
uh at this point there is go to page a
title if you can so page eight with the
number of people uh so more than a
million creditors could be affected by
the FTX uh fallout and it's chapter 11
bankruptcy filing last week FTX
indicated that it had more than a
hundred thousand creditors claiming this
case in its updated filing on Tuesday
the company cited new estimates as set
forth
in the debtors petitions there are more
than there are over a hundred thousand
creditors in these chapter 11 cases in
fact there could be more than one
million creditors in these chapter 11
cases the updated Court filing says
usually in such cases debtors are
required to provide a list and with
names and addresses of the top 20
unsecured creditors but given the
large-scale FTX debts The Firm intends
to provide a list of top 50 creditors by
Friday during the weekend FTX was also
hit by a hacking attack which resulted
in a theft of 400 million dollars worth
of tokens just accidentally just
happened this week random uh situation
that obviously it's very random with
this company and now the lawsuit is
tying in names like Brady Steph Curry
Gizelle Shaq and a bunch of other guys
that are part of this lawsuit but the
part that was interesting was the mom's
article that she wrote for Stanford in
2013 mean Sam bankman Freed's Professor
mother penned 2013 essay shredding
philosophy of personal responsibility so
you can tell she's a big Iron Rand
person if you want to go a little lower
go a little lower here to the article so
the mothers on Amazon a Founder Pharmacy
of the new bankrupt FTX company Stanford
law professor Penny 2013 arguing that it
is time for Americans to ditch
the philosophy of personal
responsibility well trust me your son
ditched it Barbara freed who just
resigned from the Democratic Super PAC
mined the Gap as the board of directors
chairperson pende 2013 essay in the
Boston Review titled Beyond blame which
argued in favor of harm reduction
policies
like Rehabilitation over incarceration
the philosophy personal responsibility
has ruined criminal criminal justice and
economic policy it's time to move past
blame public reactions to wrongdoings
have been studied most extensively and
the context of crime researchers have
found that people uh evaluations of
serious wrongfulness very significantly
cross-social conditions and individuals
tellingly the more information people
have a about the context of the crime
the person who committed it and the
circumstances he or she came from the
more nuanced are their views of moral
responsibility yesterday you're on Fox I
think the question was being asked I
don't know if it was yesterday maybe
like nine days ago or so it could have
been yesterday and question was asked
about what's going on and he said listen
I just want us to follow the law what is
the law that we have you know if people
are breaking the law you know we got to
do something about it if these guys are
stealing and getting away with it we
ought to do something about it what do
you think about what's going on right
now with FTX where AI whose company was
valued at 32 billion when you raised two
billion dollars net worth 16 billion
dollars takes the company from 32 to
zero
there's nothing new Under the Sun I mean
Enron
differences you know Enron was in the
energy space and we all knew that
underneath all of this thing was a thing
that we all desperately needed it was
energy you know what's under this thing
that uh
all I see is Hope and Faith and a notion
that something is going to be worth more
today than it was yesterday I don't
understand what the asset is really
so you know in when there's nothing
tangible to point to
you know I mean I the thing about this
story that interests me is you know
what's what's Tom Brady thinking today
and what what's what's Bill Clinton
thinking right when you see that clip of
him sitting there next to this guy in
cargo shorts who's clearly on the
Spectrum just babbling nonsense the
number of credible people who who sat
next to this guy that's David Rubinstein
from Carlisle group he's going to be on
the podcast in a couple weeks what four
billion dollars a guy [ __ ] sitting
there not [ __ ] there he's sitting
there with shorts yeah it's like hey
what's up David now look on the one hand
to our earlier point I I don't want my
own cognitive dissonance to look at this
guy and conclude that you know he's an
asshat because he he's jittery and he
wears shorts and he's got a funny
haircut and whatever
what's really going on what's what's
really under a collapse of a 32 billion
dollar company is
beyond my pay grade other than a lot of
people
uh propped this guy up a lot of people
for whatever reason said yeah him
yeah yeah let's do that and uh and the
next thing you know it's collapsing
under its own weight
so I mean it's a horrible thing to watch
but it's funny what you said about Fox I
was on there a month ago and they had a
live audience and somebody asked me what
would you do if you were president like
what what one thing would you do
and uh you know that's the one yeah
that's the one yeah yeah I said well for
starters let's let's enforce the laws on
the books because if you don't do that
then this 32 billion dollar story is
going to actually rhyme really easily
with the videotapes of Smash and grabs
all over the place
in the sense that we need to see a
consequence for this and when you don't
see a consequence you know when when
you're shown a border that's clearly
insecure when you're shown people
falling from the sky during a withdrawal
from a place like Afghanistan that was
clearly botched you know when you can
see
clearly the fact of a thing and then
you're told definitively that it's
something else
then then you really do have a level of
cognitive dissonance that goes Way
Beyond oh the Dirty Jobs guy used to
sing the Opera and it goes back to the
very first thing we were talking about
this bag is not a toy don't stick your
finger in the fan and you find yourself
looking at the other people in the room
going are you kidding me
are you so you're really going to tell
me not to stick my finger in a fan are
you kidding me you're really going to
tell me that I should put my retirement
money into a pension plan that's going
to invest heavily in a company
based on that guy
really
so I it for me it it all comes back to
the absurdity of being told that the bag
is not a toy this kid right you're gonna
tell me with a straight face that this
kid ought to be running a 32 billion
dollar company you're going to print all
right you're in charge of a newspaper
and you're going to print
an article from a woman who says what we
need in our country right now is less
personal responsibility that's his mom
that's his mom right so look things are
things will fall into place things will
start to make sense but the bigger
question is what what's the publisher
thinking why what who would print an
article like that why would you do that
you know you mentioned that he's clearly
on the Spectrum no apparently like this
is what you're well can you go to that
picture with the shorts this kid's been
built up for years 30 under 30 right so
for me one of the cues on being on the
spectrum is like your ability or your
inability to take social cues okay so
like you look at a picture like this
you're sitting down with a full-on
billionaire doing an interview for
Bloomberg all right we're familiar with
Mark Zuckerberg and he shows up in a
T-shirt and what have you he's built up
a legitimate business whether it's
controversial now we can have a whole
discussion about here's this kid
shows up looking like this like just
rolled up out of bed at what point in
your life
do you say yep I'm just going to show up
in sweatpants cut off socks slippers
frazzled hair the amount of disrespect
it takes to show up to an interview like
this with a credible businessman to me
is like a Telltale sign of of course
something was off yeah okay like the
Zuckerberg thing all right t-shirt you
know that's you know Silicon Valley but
to try to pull off this look not taking
social media he's he's it's not even you
want that from the that's what your
expectation of this guys he's not going
to give it to you this is not a guy that
sees himself dude his girlfriend's
father was the ex-sec chairman that this
there's so much stuff with this guy that
people don't even know about what he was
tied to like the amount of protection
this guy had the you know but but going
back to it you know there's a picture of
him if you can pull up him with Bill
Clinton Tony Blair and Bill Clinton on
the same stage with this guy I don't
know if you've seen that picture now
that's really yeah yeah that's what I
was talking about yeah that's the
weirdest one that's when you see
something like that you're like what the
hell is going on here right I mean I
understand David Rubenstein you want to
come in and say hey I'm a bigger deal
than you fine that's Bill Clinton and
Tony Blair look at the way he's dressed
I'm totally with you but disrespectful
but but forget let's forget that part
let's just say okay fine so this is your
style no problem fine the the paper
trail mom says let's avoid personal
responsibility it's interesting how you
mentioned Enron you know who was one of
our keynote speakers we I put an event
together two months ago at the Diplomat
and I a couple thousand entrepreneurs
show up from around the world
one of our keynote speakers was Andy
fast style you know Andy fast house
anyways the CFO of Enron that went to
jail for eight years yeah I brought him
everyone's like we're still trying to
figure out why you brought this guy here
I said I want to keep you out of jail
because he got up and he says one year I
was the CFO of the year next year this
is my ID to the jail I lived in for
eight years that's the opening speech
okay Andy fastel but can you bring up
that
um what is that but yeah can you
demonstrate she was what uh yeah I just
read that a minute ago can you bring up
the uh Instagram post of the comparison
of uh this versus Lehman's Brothers go
back to the first slide go back all the
way down to the first one okay so
billions of dollars seem to have
disappeared with the collapse of FTX how
does this even happen go to the next one
uh the collapse of FTX was a vaporized
billions of dollars in customers money
or shaking the confidence of Market that
was already in Thrones of a log in
brutal downturn okay great go to the
next one okay there are some useful
historical comparisons but none paint a
complete picture simply because cryptos
values by Nature uh derived purely from
the specular opinions that the Traders
and investors willing to buy and sell
okay fine but but watch this one here go
to the next one a big difference
between the implosion of FTX and the
downfall of Lehman Brothers in 2008 it
is shocking Mike when you see the stats
is that Lehman's Brothers had more than
600 billion dollars in assets that while
partially liquid at the time were real
assets and could be recovered in the
aftermath of Lehman's collapse it's 111
000 customers received the 106 billion
dollars they were owed and secured
creditors received full payouts sure
Lehman Brothers Equity investors were
completely wiped out you bought the
stock as will be the investors in FTX
but that's the risk Equity investors
assume when they buy and totally get it
I bought a stock go to the next one what
can't be said in the FTX customers will
be made whole on the billions of dollars
evaporated from accounts in part driven
by customer funds being used with
leveraged by ftx's sister company
Alameda who he was dating the CEO
researched to make up for loss is by
trading liquid tokens according to a
report from Financial Times
FTX had less than one billion dollars on
liquid assets against nine billion on
liabilities compared that to Lehman
Brothers who went bankrupt with 630
billion 639 billion in assets
613. if you compared it to Lima should
have never gone out of business they
just tipped the schedule that's insane
to me when you see this comparison Tom
it is the comparisons are out there and
consequences out there like today is a
very telling day uh we all know who
Elizabeth Holmes is the nice young lady
who took nearly a billion dollars from
investors yes that's correct and put a
Secretary of State on the uh on her
board yeah that's right secretary of
state knows a lot about making uh uh
medicine
um and her Playbook remember she blamed
oh it's my lover uh my CEO Sunny balwani
remember that it was like 48 and she was
like 26.
um and she had that in there but today
today in Superior right there in Santa
Clara County she's being sentenced today
her sentencing hearing is today it might
be happening right now and we're gonna
find out is there another set of laws
for people who are well connected and
can lawyer up or is she going to get the
sentencing that's due and we've seen
during the year waiting for the
sentencing she's had one child and then
got pregnant again and there is a leak
of people close to her that said that
was the plot to get married and then to
have a child and a half
in order to have some sort of an
influence on the court as we come into
the sentencing hearing
true story and you know who he's blaming
he's blaming his the article reads FTX
claims to uh be uh releasing uncensored
sex tape allegedly between this gray
sandbankment freed and Alameda CEO
Caroline Ellison soon this is a story
that's coming out and he's blaming his
ex-lover for FTX collapse and 32 billion
Auto loss admits he lied about being
moral
we woke westerners Play here's a word he
used a dumb game we woke westerners play
gotta love this guy he just I mean you
read about the scale like you know I won
you know a very inspirational type of a
character
your Maxwell quote earlier right once
you
once you figure out how to persuade
now you have to decide what you're going
to do are you going to use your powers
for good or evil you know and Adam when
you start talking about you know a sign
of disrespect it's interesting because
the Zuckerberg shows up in a T-shirt and
this guy shows up in cargo pants and you
know it's it doesn't quite land the same
way except that it did I mean look at
Bill Clinton look at is that that's Tony
Blair right yes I mean former prime
minister of the
two of the most powerful men on the
planet are sitting next to this this guy
and um they have to decide you know is
he so incredibly comfortable in his own
skin is he so amazingly authentic that
that we're now feeling we're The
Establishment we're we're stodgy we're
we we're fake in our ridiculous suits
and ties this guy's the real deal I
guarantee you a lot of people who
invested in him
saw him as authentic and persuasive
precisely because he was disrespectful
in the traditional way and I just you
know I every single day there's in my
life anyway there's a moment where I
have to like think about that last night
I presented an award at the Patriot
Awards and right up to the last minute I
couldn't decide
if I should wear a tie and I never
really agonize over this stuff too much
but some people are in tuxedos and then
they're at the next table or the guys
from Duck Dynasty and they got their
beards in their flannel shirts and they
don't give a [ __ ] right they don't care
and then you know it's it's just very
hard to know in this world where where
people have a perception of you
how do you dress and when when do you
stop trying to fit in in that
traditional sense in the end I put a tie
on just because you know I'm I just
thought that was a smart thing to do and
frankly my shirt didn't fit great kind
of bunching up a little bit but the
point is right now it's obvious right
now there's there's nothing authentic
right really there's nothing impressive
here you know but in the moment with 32
billion dollars behind you sold the
caricature of the mad scientist correct
I'll say one thing real quick for me
this comes down to knowing the
difference between right and wrong so
you use the the coin analogy right and
you can be awkward and you know
authentic and I'm just keeping it real
and I'm showing up with shorts and cargo
shorts and with the sitting with a
former president United States and
former prime minister okay cool but
there's a track record here okay the
look The Hair the shorts to me
disrespectful not reading the room not
just you know showing showing class all
right what he's accused of is
commingling funds right and taking money
from Alameda capital
and using it to fund FTX and whatever
that was that was clearly wrong called
fraud fraud okay thank you the dating of
the CEO and you know that whole thing
and whether that was appropriate or not
you know this is that's why I asked you
sort of the the um on the Spectrum thing
the the thing you hear about the
spectrum is that you're not taking
social cues and you're just sort of
disregarding social norms and their
traditions and norms for a reason right
and it just seems to me that you know he
was hiding under the guys if I'm the
smartest guy in the room trust me all
this bitty Bob's crypto and blockchain
like just trust me I'm smarter than all
of you but behind the scenes it's kind
of almost like behind the curtain The
Wizard of Oz or the emperor has no
clothes on it turns out that he was
actually just a fraudster and just
completely being disrespectful here
here's what else is missing right I
don't know exactly what that event was
but if those two guys were there then
there were lot of other people there
there was a lot of security there there
was a lot of money there right every
everything was there except somebody
in charge who had the balls to say sam
not in that outfit right okay it's
called a dress code right and we don't
care what you've done or who you are but
it just it's as simple as a dress code
you know there there are many many many
many many many restaurants that you
wouldn't be allowed to walk into dressed
like that you really think you're going
to sit down here with two of the most
powerful men on the planet you know
looking like a skater
no you know and guess what we just
Googled you and it seems you can afford
a jacket and tie go get one right there
was no one there to say it because
saying that would have been about the
most uncool thing in the world so that
guy doesn't have he's not subjected to
dress codes he's not subjected to what
you said Tom we're going to find out if
the rules apply to Ms Holmes all right
the rules don't apply to him not yet
they're about to they're gonna
well I mean listen again it goes back to
how uh certain people on how they race
kids I'm now not surprised when I read
an article like that when your mom says
we gotta get away from personal
responsibility who else do you have left
to impress in the world you know when
you when your mom's like don't worry
about it son it's you know if my mom
says this I'm gonna do this
anyone surprised I'm not surprised you
know the the biggest pushback I get from
people today is the fact that the
scholarship program we run is called a
work ethic scholarship and one of the
things you have to do to apply is you
have to sign a document called The Sweat
pledge which I wrote 12 years ago stands
for skills and work ethic aren't taboo
yeah I had had some wine beforehand and
I was trying to articulate the basic
principles that had been important to me
growing up and it helped me achieve some
measure of success and the same
principles that every employer I know
quietly craves and in the workforce and
uh
and the pushback today is you know work
ethic has become a bad word personal
responsibility has become a triggering
word
um a positive attitude you know you
start preaching that stuff then you're
part of the patriarchy you're you're
part of the problem you talk about
delayed gratification well then you're
just in the pocket of the man so all of
these traditional tropes have become
weird targets today
and I just think that uh part of that's
going on here too for her to take it to
the point that she's saying not only is
personal responsibility not the most
important thing but it's the enemy
dude you like Lockheed Martin of all of
all companies about a year ago came out
with a uh
a statement that identified uh certain
words is no longer appropriate to be
used within their uh within their
protocols within their training
materials and so forth work ethic was on
the list get out of here ambition was on
the list when you start right and so the
language is is Shifting under our feet
and Adam you you said it perfectly
before
um the emperor has no clothes this is
the world we're living in right now
where we're being shown a thing that's
crystal clear and we're being told that
it's not there
and if you remember the end of Hans
Christians Anderson's great story you
know it it was a kid
it was a kid in the crowd who who
finally said out loud you know the
emperor has no clothes that dude's naked
yeah exactly that dude's naked hey I
don't know and then people start to nod
their head and then more going on right
but it's amazing how he was able to fool
even the smartest people in the world
everyone who was so used to traditional
Norms traditional what's the quote by
Jim Cramer who's been wrong on a bunch
of things lately and though he's very
entertaining Jim Cramer JP Morgan of
this generation is Sam bankman freed
like that exactly
so it's like he even fooled some of the
smartest people because they're like oh
this is new this is like totally
different like we gotta go with this but
that's the thing right right those the
the smart people want to be fooled they
want to be fooled except for Warren
Buffett what do you think about Elon
Musk
I'm I'm Pro musk you know I'm I'm glad
he's out in the world I'm glad he's
taken big swings you know I don't agree
with him on everything but uh he'll get
us to Mars
you know
um as far as the electric cars and all
the other stuff beats me I don't know
I'm a I'm a classic energy guy
personally I don't think we have any
hope uh if we make fossil fuels the
enemy I think there's great hope in
exploring all kinds of Alternatives but
uh I'm I'm up to my neck in this
conversation you know big time were they
they're three billion people on this
planet whose primary source of energy is
burning wood and dung three billion
China and India combined are opening a
coal-fired plant every week and have
plans to continue doing so for the next
30 Years
so when when I look at our energy policy
uh absolutely explore and and develop
every alternative you can but when we
make energy when we make fossil fuels
the enemy good God man we're we're
opening a Pandora's Box that's going to
make this thing look like
Small Potatoes the dinosaurs had it
coming let's use them up
huh
they're making a great case for it
though and then anytime you I mean at
this pace uh I don't know if you are
aware of this or not uh based on what
many scientists and Congress women from
New York are saying we only have 12 more
years left to live oh Jesus if you're a
few we have by the way you know the two
girls that threw tomato soup against the
Picasso painting we had them on the
podcast no no joke just two weeks ago oh
no I'm telling you live on the podcast
and I said so tell me what are you
really afraid of
it's like what do you mean we're really
afraid of I said you really believe you
could like what I I'm afraid I'm gonna
lose the right to live a full life I
said so you so I said why do you think
insurance companies are still insurance
people insuring people saying you're
going to live to 90 95 years so why do
you think life insurance is getting
cheaper don't you think these people who
are smart people would Underwriters
saying they're going to dive in 12 die
in 12 years the other girl says no I
think people are dying now
we may not see next year and she's
straight up serious yeah the the current
educational system you said something
about college when you said
education is it valuable sure is it
worth at any cost well of course not
right
about it it's a cost for everything yeah
so it's interesting seeing how these
kids are coming out of college and
they're afraid that the world's coming
to an end it makes a parent wonder if
you want to send your kids to some of
these institutions because you may lose
them if they go to some of these
institutions I'll tell you it'd be a
terrific guest for you uh Michael
schellenberger if you haven't talked to
him already he was on my podcast
um about two months ago I love his
Twitter feed oh it's terrific man it's
so good empathy quick and right yeah and
and he was a couple minutes late to the
podcast because he was he was watching
uh
a guy run on to the tennis court and lit
his arm on fire uh during a Roger
Federer thing and it was a climate
activist who he who he described as a as
a climate uh narcissist right and he
said that's what's going on that's if if
you're a person who who glues their hand
to the wall after throwing tomato soup
on a Priceless work of art
um it doesn't it doesn't matter
why you did it or what your conscious
explanation is for doing it what you
really want is to be looked at
you want to be seen and that's
unfortunately how we reward those people
you're not on a tennis court and light
your arm on fire you want to be seen and
then you'll talk about whatever the
cause of the day is but um it's uh his
journey is extraordinary because he was
he was kind of a hippie his parents were
hippies and and he was very very much
into the environmental movement and into
the whole pushback against climate
change but he just got to the point
where he began connecting dots and came
to the conclusion that what's good for
the climate was was was very bad for the
environment and he's looking at Birds
millions of birds uh not only being
killed by windmills but being killed by
solar Farms calls them streamers right
in like Ivan Paul out in the desert
these these large condors and Eagles
will be flying and the reflection coming
off of the panels
they explode in midair
happens every day and they fall to the
ground like fireworks
so you know he he's he just went on an
odyssey and came to the conclusion that
the only sensible way out of this really
is going to be nuclear and the way to
get to nuclear is going to be to help
the world go through the hierarchical
process of coal to gas you know oil and
cleaner versions of all of those things
and and all all of these things have to
happen he ran for governor he only got a
a couple percent of the vote in
California but
um his journey is incredible his Ted
Talk is amazing he's got his head
screwed on in a really really
interesting way and he's become a Jagged
Little Pill for for that side because
he's he's of them and he he wants what
we all want you know a cleaner safer
better Planet but um look it's hard to
it's hard to argue with him when he
points to France and talks about you
know 98 of the energy that they're
generating the electricity they're
generating is nuclear and a dirty little
truth nobody wants to know about is the
Chernobyl and Three Mile Island reactors
are seven generations back of the
reactors the small reactors that they
have today like France they're smaller
and they don't have to be right next to
the ocean to use one million gallons of
pass-through water a day right it's just
amazing and nobody seems to understand
that and uh it is actually clean it's
actually efficient it's not railroad
cars full of rods that go on the death
train and they're in the salt mines
underneath Nevada I'm going to remember
the Maxwell quote more than anything
else from today except for that release
thing but uh
but no you know what once you have your
powers of of persuasion what are you
going to do with them you know what are
you going to do with them this guy's
very persuasive I I I I love what he's
doing but well I think I think you've
talked about him before and I I want to
say I follow him on Twitter because you
know was a topic of discussion we had
about him and I got curious and I
started following what he has to say
interesting guy but uh it it has been a
pleasure to uh finally have you here on
link up truly I've been looking forward
to this for a long time me too uh the
conversation was unbelievable I learned
a lot from you uh and your journey and
what you've done and the audience uh
obviously loved it and uh a lot of we
know they loved it based on uh it's 100
facts because it's 100 facts there's
certain things in life Mike is 100 on
the internet this is one of them it's a
100 fact good but uh next time next time
we do a part two of this I want to
coordinate a full day of our council
meeting together I want them to go to
dinner together lunch bring all the
paperwork or
uh Once Upon a Time
during the shooting is somebody's got to
do it the same exact thing happened I
was doing a story on a woman who had
created uh us basically the perfect
chicken and we were going to meet her
and talk to her about how all this
breeding had had led to this perfect
perfect chicken that high-end
restaurants were selling for 70 bucks a
platter and and the farm that she had
been leasing uh to you know raise these
chickens was owned by some Mennonites
and the production company had sent out
the releases and you know everybody had
signed them but we didn't realize that
her Farm the farm where we were going to
be shooting was owned by these
Mennonites and and then so we show up
and we're ready to go and we're like oh
you know what we need a location release
and the guy looks at it he's like I
I would never I would never sign
something like this why would I ever
sign something like this and then my
poor producer's like well you know in in
order to be on TV and what why why would
I ever want to be on TV what's a TV what
are you even talking about Mom and so I
finally stepped and I'm like look
we're here to tell her story she leases
your land and she's raising her chickens
we think she's doing a cool thing he
says I have no problem with that please
you're you're welcome be my guest I'm
like thank you it's just that you know
we have to shove this nasty piece of
paper up your ass okay because that's
just how the business works and he's
like well surely you understand that I I
would never ever under any circumstances
sign anything generated by anyone else
especially at the last minute and I
looked at him I said I was like you know
what he's right why why we we should
have found a way to get to him earlier
and sooner and and so I handed him a pen
and I said
could you just jot down what you would
be comfortable with
and he says I Josiah blankety blank
blank
um welcome you to my land and promise uh
not to sue you
and he signed it and I called the
production company I said listen we're
either shooting or we're not this guy
just wants to shake my hand and he wrote
one sentence he said you're like read
the sentence again and I read it and
they're like could you put it I'm like
no dude I can't put in anything this is
it yeah this is it yeah so we shook
hands and everything was fine got it
right and so I'm not saying that as some
sort of weird metaphor for what happened
here but it was a moment in time that's
a good story I'll never forget it yeah
man I'll never forget so in other words
he was a bad influence on you and he
inspired you today
I wouldn't be here without him
I'm sure you guys enjoyed it today have
a great weekend we got a bunch of
podcasts and stuff going out to uh good
you were gonna say something next week
next week
oh shoot next week we're doing a JFK
special debate three people we have here
that I'll be interviewing that is is it
two or three that they're gonna be
talking about one says the traditional
story is right the other says no no
actually the hardest thing to find was
somebody that actually believes the
traditional story that's what I'm saying
one that's the hardest thing yeah so
it's gonna be it's gonna be a fun debate
we'll have next week and uh if we don't
talk between now and the podcast you
missed next week for JFK have a Happy
Thanksgiving take care everybody